so after introducing the idea of fluid
rotation in a vector field like this
let's start tightening up our grasp on
this intuition to get something that we
can actually apply formulas to so a
vector field like the one that I had
there that's 2-dimensional is given by a
function that has a two-dimensional
input and a two-dimensional output and
it's common to write the components of
that output as the functions P and Q so
each one of those P and Q takes in two
different variables as its input P and Q
and what I want to do here is talk about
this idea of curl and you might write it
down as just curl curl of V the vector
field which takes in the same inputs
that the vector field does and because
this is the two-dimensional example I
might write just to distinguish it from
three-dimensional curl which is
something we'll get later on 2d curl of
V so you're kind of thinking of this as
a differential thing in the same way
that you have you know a derivative d/dx
it's going to take in some kind of
function and you give it a function and
it gives you a new function the
derivative here you think of this 2d
curl as like an operator you give it a
function a vector field function and it
gives you another function which in this
case will be scalar valued and the
reason a scalar valued is because at
every given point you want it to give
you a number so if I look back at the
vector field that I have here we want
that at a point like this where there's
a lot of counterclockwise rotation of
happening around it so the curl function
to return a positive number but at a
point like this where there's some
counter where there's a clockwise
rotation happening around it we want the
curl to return a negative number so
let's start thinking about what that
should mean and a good way to understand
this two-dimensional curl function and
start to get a feel for it is to imagine
the quintessential 2d curl scenario or
let's say you have a point and this here
is going to be our point XY sitting off
somewhere in space and let's say there's
no vector attached to it as in the
values P and Q at x and y are 0 and then
let's say that to the right of it you
have a vector pointing straight up above
it and the vector field if a vector
pointing straight to the left to its
left you have one pointing straight down
and below it you have one pointing
straight to the right so in terms of the
functions what that means is this vector
to its right what
a point its evaluated at that's going to
be Q is greater than zero so this
function Q that corresponds to the Y
component the up-and-down component of
each vector when you evaluate it at this
point to the right of our XY point Q is
going to be greater than zero whereas if
you evaluate it to the left over here Q
would be less than zero less than zero
in our kind of perfect
curl will be positive example and then
these bottom guys if you start thinking
about what this means for you'd have a
rightward vector below and a leftward
vector above the one below it whatever
point you're evaluating that at P which
gives us the kind of left/right
component of these vectors since it's
the first component of the output would
have to be positive and then above it
above it here when you evaluate P at
that point it would have to be negative
whereas P if you did it on the left and
right points would be equal to zero
because there's kind of no X component
and similarly Q if you did it on the top
and bottom points since there's no
up-and-down component of those vectors
would also be zero so this is just the
very specific almost contrived scenario
that I'm looking at and I want to say
hey if this should have positive curl
maybe if we look at the information the
partial derivative information to be
specific about P and Q in a scenario
like this it will give us a way to
quantify the idea of curl and first
let's look at P so P starts positive and
then as Y increases is the Y value of
our input increases it goes from being
positive to zero to negative so we would
expect that the partial derivative of P
with respect to Y so as we change that Y
component moving up in the plane and
look at the X component of the vectors
that should be negative that should be
negative in circumstances where we want
positive curl so all of this we're
looking at cases you know the
quintessential case where curl is
positive so evidently this is a fact
that corresponds to positive curl where
as Q let's take a look at Q it starts
negative when you're at the left and
then becomes 0 then it becomes positive
so here as x increases Q increases so
we're expecting that a partial
derivative of Q with respect to X should
be positive or at the very least that
situations where the partial derivative
of Q with respect to X is positive
corresponds to positive two-dimensional
curl and in fact it turns out these guys
tell us all you need to know we can say
as a formula that the 2d curl 2d curl of
our vector field V as a function of x
and y is equal to the partial derivative
of Q with respect to X partial
derivative of Q with respect to X and
then I'm going to subtract off the
partial of P with respect to Y because I
want when this is negative for that to
correspond with more positive 2d curl so
I'm going to subtract off partial of P
with respect to Y this right here is the
formula for two-dimensional curl which
basically you can think of it as a
measure at any given point you're asking
how much does the surrounding
information to that point look like this
set up like this perfect counter
clockwise rotation set up and the more
it looks like this set up the more this
value will be positive and if it was the
opposite of this if each of the vectors
was turned around and you have clockwise
rotation each of these values would
become the negative of what it had been
before so 2d curl would end up being
negative and in the next video I'll show
some examples of what it looks like to
use this formula